AJ is up AJ is in Los Angeles hi AJ
welcome to Dave Ramsey show your
question for Christian me hey Dave um so
my question is is uh so like most
Americans and working from home right
now and man I'm not a lot I love it I
have like more time with my family
um I'm saving a ton of money in gas and
then toll so overall it's working out
really well and the thing is I have a
job where I can actually work from home
and still get the same amount done and I
haven't I haven't I've been producing
the same amount of work maybe even a
little bit more my question is is what
would be after all this Corona masters
done like is there a way I can ask my
company and what is the right way to ask
my company I could just work from home
what do you do I'm a draft okay how long
have you been working from home three
years attender no I'm sorry how long
have you just been working from home
doing what you do from home
okay so here's all my saying I'm curious
what you as the CEO of a company Dave
and you're real big on us being here so
I'm curious about your thoughts on this
AJ I'm wondering if you feel like that
after three more weeks if you feel like
that after six weeks of being home
because right now everything is new and
shiny oh my gosh I can do video calls
and my pajamas this is so awesome but
after the newness wears off I'm curious
if you still want that type of setup and
some people do some people prefer that
for the benefits you just listed some
people actually like driving to a place
the camaraderie the collaboration the
creativity that happens in a team
environment the having a reason to put
on jeans for the day the productivity
whenever you're actually present with
the people that you work with so I'm
curious if this stays or if this is
something that just feels new and
different right now but Dave what would
you say is as someone that took all
that's a really good call I think if it
does if it does stand the test of time
and meaning you still like it in four
weeks and you may be there in four weeks
the if it stands the test of time
meaning you still feel that way about it
that you do right now the way you ask
the company is you just ask the company
you just say I feel like I've gotten
more work done I like doing this is
would you consider this and be ready for
a yes or a no answer okay and you know I
lay out
yeah just lay out what you just laid out
to us and but don't you know you're
you're you're asking pretend like you
owned the company how would you want
someone to ask you not with belligerence
and demanding I would just fire your
little butt okay alright but if you go
in there within say hey you know Dave I
won't be part of the team but I think
I'm doing more this way I'm more
comfortable this way and try to make
your case your you know your owner may
want to do that there are some companies
that do there are a lot of companies
that do some work from home pre
coronavirus and they will be post I will
tell you up front to Christie's to go
along with what Christy's saying we have
a lot of developers on our team and a
lot of creatives on our team that used
to work from home as freelance and
missed human interaction and joined our
team because they wanted to be on a team
and physically want to be on a team and
they have a hashtag going around now
working from home blow okay so they
liked the you know they joined us out of
the wild and became part of Ramsey
because they want to be around highly
intelligent highly effective people
energized by it and and didn't like
working at home as much as they thought
so check it out before a week see if you
still like it before you make the
proposal good question good ideas